[Música]
para que una sociedad viva en armonía
ocupamos
de hecho
tortilla
trabajo y hoy vengo a agregar el tiempo
como madre de familia y administradora
de hogar de cuatro hijos cada vez se me
hace más difícil poder balancear mi
tiempo entre mi hogar mi familia mis
amistades o sea mis responsabilidades ya
sea mi trabajo o mis estudios
entonces para poder alcanzar el balance
entre estas cuatro test es importante
que aprendamos a manejar un factor en
común entre ellas
el dinero quien dijo que aprender a
manejar nuestra relación con el dinero
fuera fácil no es fácil
entonces esto fue lo que me motivó a mí
como a poder expresar y ayudar a
compartir todos mis conocimientos de
finanzas personales y a poder ayudar a
miles de personas para que puedan lograr
una prosperidad integral según una
encuesta de una institución financiera
hondureña el 75% de las personas de
nuestro país nos sentimos fuera de
control con nuestras finanzas personales
ya sea porque tenemos que pagar deudas
tenemos que pagar nuestras cuentas
tenemos que aprender cómo saber ahorrar
o cómo invertir nuestro dinero entonces
por qué pasa esto muchas razones
tenemos una cultura de consumismo dentro
de nuestro país queremos comprar todo lo
que nosotros vemos
falta del hábito del ahorro cuántas de
las personas que estamos aquí tenemos el
buen hábito de ahorrar
también falta de educación financiera
porque muchos creen que la educación
financiera no es para ellos cuando
realmente la educación financiera es
para todos muchas de las personas
también piensan que es cuestión de
ingresos
pero la norma es que entre más ganamos
más gastamos
y cómo solucionamos cuántos de ustedes
dicen ok para mantener una alimentación
saludable voy a ir al gimnasio o voy a
hacer una dieta entonces para mantener
finanzas sanas hoy les propongo varias
soluciones
la primera es el presupuesto el
presupuesto es la base y el corazón de
las finanzas saludables la base el
presupuesto es lo que nos ayudará a
poder controlar mejor nuestro dinero
para poder monitorear nuestros gastos de
la mejor manera posible
también nos dirá si tenemos que pase al
endeudamiento tenemos no sólo adquirir
préstamos así por así porque nosotros
queremos tener un carro o porque
queremos adquirir una casa sino ayudarlo
a hacer de la mejor manera posible
cuántos de ustedes saben distinguir bien
la diferencia entre necesidad y un deseo
los hondureños pensamos que lo
necesitamos absolutamente todo hoy da
una charla por la mañana y él decía ok
para poder emprender
necesitamos tener ciertos buenos hábitos
y uno debe ser el ahorro y me dice una
amiga de la mañana una de las
emprendedoras nunca logró ahorrar este
es mi problema y le digo quiere que yo
le diga el por qué usted no logra
ahorrar y me dice sí y baja la cabeza y
me y le digo yo usted compra todo lo que
ve usted cree que lo necesita todo y eso
es ahí está es parte del consumismo
entonces hoy les digo antes de que vayan
a hacer un gasto deben preguntarse a sí
mismas
es realmente necesario o no es realmente
necesario lo necesito o lo quiero está
dentro de mi presupuesto o no está
dentro de mi presupuesto suena sencillo
pero al final no es nada sencillo y es
tantito complicado otra es el trabajo el
valor del trabajo el que quiera tener
que se faje
sí o no
yo mis días desde que comencé con la
consejería financiera siempre me dicen
ay mami y esto cuánto cuesta y esto
cuánto cuesta y esto es gratis y le dio
yo nada en la vida que es gratis el que
quiere tener que se faje porque todo en
la vida cuesta
y finalmente
el hábito del ahorro
el hábito del ahorro es de los hábitos
más importantes para poder sanar
nuestras finanzas personales porque el
futuro de nosotros es incierto
no sabemos qué viene entonces qué pasa
cuando tenemos un problema de salud y
qué pasa también cuando hay un accidente
a dónde recurrimos obviamente que si
tenemos nuestros ahorros va a ser mucho
más fácil pero si no tenemos ese dinero
a mano que va a pasar adquirimos una
presta un préstamo una deuda y eso
obviamente que va a ser dinero que sale
mucho más caro porque ese dinero que
vamos a adquirir tiene un costo tenemos
que pagar intereses entonces esa es una
manera de poder solucionar este tipo de
problemas que estamos viviendo dentro de
nuestro país ahora
cuántas decisiones tomamos a diario
en base al dinero desde comprar una taza
de café a donde vamos a saber dónde
vamos a invertir nuestros ahorros son
alrededor más o menos entre unas seis y
diez decisiones diarias
quieres tener un viaje a roatán
quieres tener un perro
bello y reconocer como decía a miami a
isis hace un tiempo un ratito atrás
bello ir a experimentar nuestra cultura
saben qué significa un viaje roatán
dejar de gastar en trescientas tazas de
café al año se han puesto a pensar
ustedes en eso
4 quieren comprarse un carro
eso significa dejar de salir a
parrandear 75 veces en el año
quieren comprarse una casa cuánto
quieren comprarse una casa yo
definitivamente todo lo que estamos acá
entonces comencemos con el hábito del
ahorro y meditemos cuántas veces salimos
a comer afuera durante la semana se han
puesto a pensar también durante la
semana el comer afuera obviamente que
eso implica un gasto más alto que estar
comiendo dentro de la casa entonces son
decisiones pequeñas que tomamos a diario
que influencian en nuestras finanzas
personales
yo creo que hoy vengo a decirles que ya
es hora que las escuelas comiencen a
cambiar sus currículums es hora que
empecemos a enseñarle a los nuestros
jóvenes de honduras a cómo poder manejar
sus finanzas personales a cómo aprender
a manejar la economía del hogar
porque estos jóvenes tienen que aprender
a elaborar un presupuesto
tienen que saber la importancia de un
crédito como adquirir y programar tener
una vivienda son cosas que cuando ya
salen de su educación no saben ni por
dónde empezar ni qué decisiones tomar
entonces lastimosamente muchas de las
personas en nuestro país empiezan a
formarse en educación financiera y a
manejar sus finanzas personales debido a
un error en el pasado
o puede ser que sus padres a través de
los años hayan guiado los
pero quiero decirles que estos errores
salen caros tienen graves consecuencias
y estas consecuencias son
tus finanzas afectan tu matrimonio
las finanzas afectan la estabilidad
familiar las finanzas afectan tu trabajo
cómo podemos ir a trabajar si nos
sentimos completamente abrumados
obviamente que si hemos tomado malas
decisiones financieras en nuestra vida
también tendremos problemas de salud
ansiedad estrés depresión migrañas
dolores de cabeza gastritis y finalmente
nuestras emociones en fin si ustedes ven
aquí son los aspectos más importantes de
nuestra vida
quiero decirles que existe una fórmula
para un montón de cosas en la vida que
es el 80 20 y el 80 20 es por ejemplo si
queremos mantener una buena salud o
queremos bajar de peso
ok existe lo que dicen que la fórmula
80% es lo que verdaderamente comemos y
20% es el ejercicio que nosotros hacemos
entonces cuál es más importante lo que
comemos para las finanzas
yo la aplico de esta manera el 80% es el
comportamiento de cada uno de ustedes
que están aquí y el 20% es el
conocimiento conocimiento es toda la
educación financiera que nosotros
podamos recibir todo lo que le damos
estudiamos pero al final depende de cómo
nos vamos a comportar cada uno de
nosotros por más conocimiento que
tengamos depende totalmente del
comportamiento entonces qué quiere decir
eso que las finanzas personales dependen
de cada uno de ustedes de los que están
aquí presentes entonces yo quiero
decirles que el dinero es importante
y me decía una amiga una señora que
conocí realmente hace un mes durante yo
estaba en el salón y me decía comenzando
a hablar de sus hijos de su familia y yo
respeto mucho a las personas mayores ya
de 84 años porque son yo considero
personas sabias que las ganas por algo
las tienen y me decía ella sin saber en
el rubro de consejería financiera que yo
estaba y me dice usted sabe me dice que
el dinero es importante pero el dinero
no es la esencia de la vida y digo yo
cuál es la verdadera esencia de la vida
la esencia de la vida es
y poder encontrar el balance entre
nuestra mente nuestro cuerpo la salud y
nuestro corazón el dinero realmente es
importante para alcanzar estas 4-3 en la
vida pero recuerden las demás cosas que
nos van a ser feliz entonces hoy por hoy
yo quiero dejarles a cada uno de ustedes
que adquieran una mente próspera y saben
que es una mente prospera el poder soñar
en grande no tengan miedo al fracaso
seamos positivos fijémonos metas en la
vida lean inviertan estudian algo nuevo
todos los días
porque si podemos alcanzar estas cuatro
test en nuestra vida y algo más que
también les quiero decir es que el
dinero no solamente es para el gobierno
el dinero no solamente es para las
empresas tampoco es para los bancos el
dinero es para cada uno de ustedes el
dinero son vivencias propias que
llevamos a diario y que hacemos a diario
así que espero que tengan muchísima
suerte en poder alcanzar esas 43 y tomar
las mejores decisiones para alcanzar un
balance en su vida muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
e
m